the team that eats the most hot dogs in
10 minutes will be declared the winner
on your mark
get set eat is there any mustard no
mustard no mustard just eat it eat it
Phyllis dip it in the water so it'll
slide down your gullet more easily
all right we have exciting news here for
someone in our Fox Family chief
meteorologist yeah that's right Janice
Dean is an official judge for the
Nathan's Famous Hot Dog Eating Contest
happening this July 4th as it does every
July 4th in Coney Island New York here's
the judge now Janice how did you get
this gig I am so jealous
I still don't know and what an honor
when I got that email Brian I I said to
my husband they want me to be an
official judge in Brooklyn on the 4th of
July uh to judge this historic hot dog
eating contest uh Joey Chestnut of
course will be back uh and his title is
76 hot dogs in 10 minutes so I believe
one of the esteemed judges that gets to
count uh not only Joey Chestnut but we
also have a competition between the
women as well Miko Sudo is also the
reigning champion of 48 hot dogs two
years ago she was pregnant last year so
she couldn't compete but what an honor
and not for the faint of heart by the
way uh because one of the judges last
year passed out apparently
I listen stay stay upright promise me
also uh it's good to see a birthing
person took a year off so let me ask you
this Janice uh what do you see your role
being as a counter are you somebody's
going to be counting are you going to
disqualify people are you gonna give
them red cards because you're wearing a
referee outfit
there are red cards uh you get the red
car if uh the red card if you reject the
hot dog that's a polite way of saying
you don't throw up the hot dog uh so you
will be disqualified I will disqualify
you if you can't keep the dogs down as
well for messy eating that's a yellow
card so if you're really messy and
you're spewing the hot dogs on the
judges like me you get a yellow card uh
but you know I'm I'm just excited about
it my whole family is coming my kids my
husband uh my sister-in-law my niece my
nephews it's gonna be crazy I mean this
is a this is an honor Brian kill me do
we know anyone on Fox and Friends that
have ever had this kind of Honor I think
you have to call me the judge after this
well oh wait a second no we went to our
official did no nobody's ever had this
honor uh I think that uh people have to
talk to Carly about it but she has not
been able to close it uh quick the last
question for you only have 45 seconds to
answer it is the hot dog a sandwich
oh my gosh that I don't I don't even
know how to go there that's going to
require more than 45 seconds uh the hot
dog is not a sandwich I have to say
what do I win not a sandwich
I don't know if you're right what do you
mean if you win I asked you a question
you can't say you can't answer the
question I'm sure you got it right and
then through Amanda prize
I'm the judge I judge myself
what time since all start at Coney
Island what time does the event begin
I am going to be on Fox and Friends
starting at 5
word and then
it shouldn't starts at 10 A.M and it
ends at 1 p.m 10 minutes for the boys 10
minutes for the girls and there will be
a champion and I will be an official
judge
I've never chanced I've known you for a
long time I've never seen you this
excited uh and I'm so happy for you and
your family they finally let they
finally are happy about what you do for
a living I appreciate it Janice thanks I
wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me
a favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now